Democratic senator Tim Kaine of Virginia
joins us from the Capitol it was a
Clinton running late in the 2016
election senator good morning morning
charlie good to be with you today what
is it that concerns you most about what
we've learned in the last 24 or 48 hours
and does it approach obstruction of
justice Charlie if the if the facts are
as they are alleged yes it would get
close to obstruction of justice there
are a few disputes though but let me
just lay it out a director of the FBI is
talking to the president and essentially
having a conversation about whether he
gets to continue in his job the
president is asking him if he's loyal
the president asked him to drop an
investigation into the National Security
Adviser the director not only doesn't
drop the investigation but he publicly
reveals it to Congress asks for more
resources for the investigation and then
gets fired and the president after some
initial hesitation acknowledges that
he's fired because of the Russia
investigation that is sort of a classic
case that will get very close to being
obstruction of justice there are two
facts in dispute did President Trump
asked Comey to drop the investigation or
not that's why we need to hear from the
director and from the president with all
notes and tapes we can get and second
there is a little bit of dispute about
whether director Comey had in fact asked
for more resources before he was fired
senator let me ask you the acting
director Andrew McCabe has testified on
Capitol Hill was asked about whether
there had been interference and said
quite clearly there has been no effort
to impede our investigation to date you
know but how do you square that with
firing the FBI director I mean I view
firing the FBI director and when asked
essentially admitting I'm doing it
because of the Russian investigation if
that's not an effort to impede or
undermine the investigation what is
especially if he had earlier asked him
he dropped this Flynn and get
investigation and director Comey refused
to are you surprised that we're just now
hearing about this memo do you think
that we should have been told about it
earlier
you know Gail not necessarily because
here's the case if if if the President
had said that to director Comey it's
suspicious
but it wasn't until the firing I you
know I might argue what until the firing
that there was an actual effort to
obstruct so you have to have an intent
to obstruct but you also have to take an
action to obstruct and the action was
the firing asking the question is very
borderline very very borderline behavior
but if that question was asked and Comey
proceeded with the investigation and
there was no firing of director Comey
it's not clear that there would then be
the actual act of obstruction but the
combination of asking him to dropping
the drop the investigation and then
firing him in citing the Russia
investigation is the reason that really
completes the the allegations and what
we need now is to hear from director
Comey and from the president about what
happened senator Tim Kaine thank you so
much we'd have to note that we reached
out to 20 Republican senators and
representatives to appear on this
broadcast we also reported and requested
that someone from the White House join
us at any point during our two-hour
broadcast to respond to the latest news
all declined our invitation